the ottawa police service has developed
an enhanced operational plan to manage
the rolling thunder event this weekend
police have established a motor vehicle
exclusion zone
and protesters will not be allowed to
drive into the downtown core as part of
the demonstration this weekend extra
resources from multiple police services
including the rcmp the opp and the
city's bylaw officers will manage public
safety assist with road closures and
enforce all criminal code bylaws and
provincial highway traffic offenses
police services board chair el shantiria
has been in constant contact with the
board and city council and i want to
thank him for being here today to
provide an update our primary focus
remains public safety and ensuring the
protest is peaceful with minimal
disruption to our residents and small
businesses in the nation's capital
ottawa police service is working with
all stakeholders and has mobilized the
resources needed to ensure that this is
the case
the city and ottawa police are in
contact with representatives of the
business improvement areas the bias to
keep them apprised of all plans and to
address any concerns that they may have
we also encourage residents to continue
to shop downtown to continue to shop the
byward market to use public transit to
get in and out of the downtown core all
measures are being taken to ensure
residents can access the programs
services and supports that the city has
to offer but residents can expect some
disruptions and traffic delays this
weekend
people certainly have the right to
protest peacefully and i want to
emphasize that no illegal activity will
be tolerated we're stepping up
enforcement and there will be
significant consequences for people who
break the law
we're monitoring the numbers and we know
that organizers have said they expect up
to 400 motorcycles
we expect that many of these individuals
will be staying in downtown hotels
there are other sites these participants
may visit including a rural property on
eagleson road and a church in vanier
any area where these participants gather
will see increased police presence and
possible traffic delays
the organizers have advised that the
participants will depart the city on
sunday we don't necessarily have
different legal remedies that are in in
place now that were in place prior to
the the
convoy one of the things i think that
that's important for us to recognize is
through the convoy we learned a lot
and our community style expectations are
somewhat different now
in the city of ottawa we've had many
many rolling uh vehicle-based protest
rallies and demonstrations in the past
that have been successfully managed the
convoy and the fallout of the convoy and
the occupation of our streets has
changed our community expectations
changed public expectations and our
policing response to these uh to these
types of events so what you're seeing is
us taking
a much more proactive
stance in terms of how we manage people
in and around that downtown core while
we work with our city partners to
establish what are the right areas to
actually manage and control and listen
to our community in public in terms of
their expectations on how rallies
demonstrations and protests roll out in
our street